Salut à toi, digne membre de la team Mentalo ! Menthe à l'eau ?
Oui, Menthe à l'eau. Alors je m'assieds car oui, contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
sur la vidéo d'hier
ce n'était pas un fond vert, j'étais pas à genoux, j'étais juste assis à
même le sol quand j'ai fait la vidéo
de ce dimanche. Depuis fin août dans les
commentaires vous me demandez comment apprendre ces cours plus rapidement
plus facilement. Alors, on va pas se mentir, il n'y a pas de méthode miracle pour ça.
Et en plus de ça j'ai déjà donné pas
mal de techniques dans beaucoup de
vidéos depuis le début de l'année, le
but de la chaîne est aussi d'être un
petit peu de pédagogie du début de
l'année à la fin de l'année.
Mais, quand vous êtes arrivé il y avait peut être déjà 200 vidéos ! Alors j'ai pris la
décision que aujourd'hui j'allais vous donner des astuces en plus et vous
faire un petit espèce de panel de
techniques et de méthode pour mieux
assimiler ces cours. La première astuce, c'est de bien écouter lors du
cours
Évidemment ! Ça paraît logique mais qui
le fait vraiment à chaque fois ? Cherchez
en permanence à comprendre à écouter
et à retenir durant le cours plutôt
qu'à re-noter. Faire des belles feuilles, des belles pages, c'est bien mais vous
pouvez les faire plus tard chez vous. Deuxième astuces c'est de relire le cours
le soir même. Même si vous avez pas cette matière-là le lendemain.
La mémoire c'est un petit peu comme une forêt, et quand vous apprenez quelque chose, vous
tracez un chemin dans cette forêt
et plus vous allez repasser sur ce
chemin-là, plus le chemin il va défini.
Lors du premier passage il n'est pas encore très creusé, ce chemin-là donc si vous y
repassez le soir même en relisant
votre cours, vous allez commencer à le
consolider, à le solidifier et je tape beaucoup trop fort dans ma main ! Troisième
actuce c'est quand vous allez vouloir
travailler ce cours, essayez à chaque
fois de vous faire une petite fiche
c'est pas vraiment une note de lecture
c'est plus une note qui va vous
permettre de mieux comprendre les choses
c'est en 5 questions. C'est quoi ? Ça
sert à quoi ? Comment ? Avec quoi ? Pourquoi ?
Peu importe que ce soit un cours de maths, un cours de géo ou un cours de
sciences, littéraire, technologie, peu
importe que c'est. Pour réussir à
répondre à ces questions, vous allez
forcément faire un petit travail de
réflexion et de compréhension. Ça va
vous obliger à avoir une vision globale
du cours. Et ce que le cerveau comprend,
le cerveau le retient. Il est pratique ce
cerveau ! Imaginons que cette vidéo
était en cours et ce n'est pas un
cours ! Ça donnerait : C'est quoi ? Une vidéo qui synthétise plusieurs méthodes pour apprendre
ces cours plus rapidement. Ça sert à quoi ? A s'optimiser, à être plus efficace
Comment ? En ayant une méthodologie
d'apprentissage. Avec quoi ? Avec
différentes astuces et c'est celles que
je donne tout le long de la vidéo donc
là je vais pas les re-synthétiser. Et pourquoi ? pour être plus efficace, perdre moins de temps quand
on apprend ses cours et surtout
rentabiliser ce temps-là dans la durée
1, 2, 3, quatrième astuces : relire ses cours
avant de s'endormir. Quand vous avez la
matière le lendemain, relisez le cours
juste avant de vous endormir, le soir
dans votre lit. Vraiment relisez-le, ne
cherchez pas à l'apprendre, juste relisez-le, c'est la nuit que la
mémoire s'organise et fait tout son
travail. Il y a des techniques avec
lesquels vous serez sûrement plus ou
moins à l'aise pour apprendre beaucoup
plus vite et dans toutes les vidéos que
j'ai pu réaliser sur la chaîne, il y
a des techniques qui sont vraiment adaptées pour ça. Je vous mets un lien des
cinq vidéos dans le descriptif. Donc : la
lecture rapide, la lecture rapide permet
donc de lire beaucoup
plus vite et d'avoir un meilleur taux de
compréhension contrairement à l'idée
reçue qui dit que plus on lit lentement et
mieux on comprend. C'est pas vrai. En
deux : les mind map j'en parle souvent
d'ailleurs il y a une vidéo avec vos mind map
qui va bientôt sortir je pense vous la faire en fin de semaine
prochaine
Si vous voulez envoyer un mind map, regardez sur la fan page de Facebook
là où tout le monde a posté la sienne,
vous mettez la votre et je m'en servirai
aussi pour la vidéo. Si vous pouvez
même faire votre prise de notes en mindmap
directement c'est excellent. Les
flash card j'ai pas fait de vidéos sur
le flash card parce que je pense que tout
le monde connaît
si vous souhaitez que je fasse une vidéo là-dessus, sur ce système-là
vous me le dites dans les commentaires.
4 : la concentration, la capacité de se
mettre en concentration avant un début
du cours ou avant des révisions, la vidéo
je l'ai faite très récemment celle-ci.
5 : apprendre n'importe quel texte j'avais
fait une vidéo là-dessus en début
d'année je vous la remet également
elle permet d’assimiler n'importe quel
texte. La méthode a l'air plus longue et plus
compliquée c'est pas vrai c'est juste un
changement d'habitude, ça vous paraîtra
plus long pour la première fois, le
premier apprentissage, mais vous aurez plus
à y revenir. Et enfin toutes les astuces
et master classe que vous trouvez dans la
playlist de la mémoire, peut sûrement vous aider à mieux apprendre et plus rapidement.
J'espère que cette vidéo qui
contient des nouvelles astuces et un
recap' de tout ce qui a été fait va
vous servir à avoir une vision globale des
outils que vous pouvez prendre vous pour
être encore plus efficace. Merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo, si vous l'avez
trouvé utile d'une manière ou d'une autre, n'hésitez
pas à le faire savoir en laisant un petit pouce en l'air ! Pensez
également à vous abonner avant de
partir, si ce n'est pas déjà fait
évidemment ! Et rendez-vous demain à 17 heures.   Ciao !!